là cái bàn, tình nó đồ được được bà khi cũng tên được nghiên trường thôi.
Y mạnh gọi của anh, đây đu.
Nhưng cái câu hợp về pháp lý này, về chính trì này, về văn hóa này.
Nhưng cái chá thì rất mạnh đạo được đạo đi.
Tì đây là cái cái mà mà cái tâm của tương nó được được được được bà.
Và đến đây chúng ta đạo đi.
Chúng tôi nghĩ là thật sự bàn nói là,
tâm của tươi rất ngắn, mà đầy biết một tị văn kiếm như thế.
Làm một cái bàn, quá, các bạn không dễ.
Phải là cái kiếp tuay hồ gì mình.
Mà tối như thế nghiệp.
Đây là thiên tại hồ gì mình.
Hơi mẹ mấy của tài biết được một cái bàn tinh của gì thế.
Chúng tôi của gọi đi.
Sok sản lý của cái bàn tinh của cản lươi.
Xì cái bàn tinh của chúng ta.
Phúc vậy chúng ta từng hắn chúng ta đâu,
nhưng thật sự là một cái bàn tinh của nó.
Đây cái hại từng hắn.
Và tại sao không cái bàn?
Chúng tôi cũng được lợp.
Sau này đường chúng ta còn bảo vệ cuối cho nó,
còn vệ cuối với giá tiếp của nó.